you must know
why people might be like why are you
tolerating this or why are you doing
this it's because my daughter's at my
Forefront you get what I mean Pearl no
she's not because if you watch that
podcast she spoke and she spoke and she
spoke and she spoke and not once did she
mention her child and that's what was so
shocking and then people watch that
podcast they will see that she didn't
mention her child and then as soon as I
heard that she mentioned a child I think
I was the first one to speak and I said
oh well you've got a child whoa this
changes it all then and that's when the
confrontation changes because she was
sitting down there as a married woman
who's left her husband because he might
cheat and she not wants it she mentioned
the child so the child cannot be the
center of your life if you don't mention
your child and I'd also like to say the
only reason she's getting this reaction
video right now is because then it was
crazy okay she chose to go on another
podcast and catch it yeah and tell lies
and that's why I won't go on their
podcast because they lie not because I'm
scared or as my mate will say let them
come for me
of course try telling me I'm being
selfish no you are being selfish because
you didn't mention your child you don't
think about your child or you're
thinking about yourself and you're even
allowing or trying to help in this
situation it's because I want my
daughter to have a such a healthy
relationship with Dad she's not out on
the street now but she's saying that
you're being selfish based on the
statistics of everyone else nobody like
a single single mother homes no no but
much but this so based on that what is a
single mother home it's mainly a woman
that might not have enough to provide
right that's wrong I was a single parent
and I was earning 40K a year and I had I
earned enough to provide a single parent
home is when you live separately so
don't try and make it about money
because otherwise you're going to say oh
but he's giving us the money where is
the emotional connection where is the
the everyday love not the part-time
after school love where is the everyday
Love Money can't replace a father in the
home and that's what these modern women
think they think that money can replace
time with their parents can't the child
might
this is gonna be like time number a
million you interrupted the man you
feminine woman mm-hmm this is what I'm
saying a child won't actually have to
see two parents living together my dad
wasn't living full time at my house for
me to have an amazing bond with him he
had he had his life back
if she had an amazing bond with her dad
she would have had her dad would have
vetted her husband before she got
married and she wouldn't have been in
the situation she is now because when
you're close to your dad you can ask
your dad advice about anything yeah so
can I ask you do you not feel like say
you are now teaching your child that
that that's okay like no because because
you're saying you want to bring them up
to like kind of have a certain sort of
morals like you want them to obviously
grow up and have a relationship and feel
like being in your family Dynamic look
at her face every time someone's like
making a point she's like does that
point hit him that's why you want him to
see that every day you're in a loving
family to a certain degree to his eyes
you're the loving family but then when
he grows up and realizes that this isn't
true then what kind of mentalities you
really kind of he's gonna have because
you ain't really you ain't really
showing him that then either because at
some point he's going to clock that well
this isn't true you've been showing me
kind of a life or my life no but it's
not that I'm light it's just that she
doesn't need to know she's sorry no it's
fine it's just that she doesn't need to
know every little obstacle that me and
her dad might have did you get what I
mean and she also understands that like
for example because I work Daddy needs
to take you because mummy's working so
it's not that she's seeing it as you
know she's just seen it as this is and I
explained to her yeah but when when
she's never seen her parents kiss when
she's never seen her parents cuddle okay
all right your kid your kid grows up and
they will talk and you whatever your
sins are swear to God your kids will
come forward they might not go on social
media but people will know if you didn't
if you didn't treat your child right I'm
sorry kids grow up and they talk yeah
family don't worry about it because Me
growing up with a polygyny household
where I had two moms I didn't know how
to explain that to people because what I
saw when I went to school one mum one
dad do you get what I mean so for me I
found it uncomfortable how do I say my
dad's got a healthy relationship with
two women and we both live together so I
found that hard and I told my child
different families of different mindsets
you don't have to worry about what
so-and-so's doing your family's like
this that's it wait wait so if you said
to your child you don't have to worry
about what so-and-so is doing that
sounds like the kid found out yeah did
you catch that yeah because otherwise
why would you have to explain yeah
because I think she's saying that way a
child must be going to school so she's
got to prepare the child what she's
basically telling the child is that
living apart from your dad is normal
yeah well and that's that's a different
family and that's what kept happening on
the podcast was she kept contradicting
herself so then if I was there I'd say
wait wait I thought you said and then
she'll be like oh she's manipulating I'm
like what are you nuts as long as she's
happy trust me she's good like and I
would
and I will do what I need to a quick
question obviously I don't want to just
focus on your thing I want to keep it
wider but do you know that's what she
done on the show were you having a show
and they end up with over half the show
on her because she wouldn't shut up now
look what the guy's saying let's focus
on something else because I don't want
it to be about your thing and that's
what she tried to make it see that there
would have been a benefit if for her if
100 together but that's why I'm making
my relationship with him that is it
would be better if they were together
100 so rather than stay here together
that's what she's saying we're gonna
separate so that we can get that 100 we
don't I don't add up can be mended if it
works out I can't force him to be okay
okay if it works out you know hold on
right it takes two to tango and that's
what Pearl was did he leave the woman no
it's just that right actually we didn't
say that I said to them I blame both of
you I remember saying that when I found
out she had a child I said it's
different now because now you've got a
child I think you're both wrong because
you're both need to work it you both
should be in the house working here so
she can't say that wasn't said you know
what about the man like if he doesn't
want it to work this is something that
women always do whenever you blame
something with
say that a woman's at fault they always
say what about the man yeah like
sometimes we can just make statements
about women without bringing men into it
yeah there's nothing you can you left
though I'm saying like who it's not that
who left it's we answer the question and
that's what you know she said that she
left and now she she's no and that's the
that's she's kind of switching she's
going around it now then that's why like
people that are if you're telling the
truth you directly answer a question
yeah agreed he initiated it that he
can't yeah
no he initiated it he initiated it by
answering her question you know they had
a conversation he said he might cheat I
know just a conversation he didn't cheat
I wonder if it's because she again I
would leave her no yeah he initiated
that he can't do the whole he doesn't do
you know what it is I think especially
because we got married young some men
don't like having someone to answer to
did you get what I mean some mental
because you're not as a feminine woman
you're not supposed to talk what a man
should answer to a woman like to be able
to call someone and say oh I can't come
home today do you get what I mean
but that's what I'm saying is and at
that point at that point I didn't
understand no but at that point I didn't
understand that why can't you tell me to
get what I mean so where now she's
blaming him now now she's letting me
know he done this and he done that he
would done whatever she never mentioned
all that on the show he felt like I
don't want to have to tell you and I
felt like well you should it was a
culture clash and it goes into the topic
we want to talk about because obviously
it's a culture class but yeah she's
bringing up her child in her own culture
and her own religion but now she's
trying to say that they're different
cultures so which culture she raising
their child in from my race do you get
what I mean is she do raising a child in
her culture the British culture like
what she said earlier the British
culture her dad's culture or her
husband's culture and it can't be it if
she stays by herself she's not raising
her kid in her culture exactly like you
can't that's like that's like okay if I
my parents are both Catholic they can't
say they raised us in a Catholic home if
they didn't stay together Catholics
don't believe in divorce exactly I had a
certain culture I wasn't saying that's
what they got so many kids that would
even contraception either
expectation on what I wanted in a man
because of my culture and if you don't
marry the same culture you're not going
to have this was there a reason why I
didn't want to say it all sorry was
there a reason why I didn't want to say
no it's just there's some women that are
like been meeting probably not like that
but like some things I just wouldn't
want to fall in town it's going to be a
headache yeah no I feel like and I feel
like I take an accountability there were
some things that I could have definitely
changed she took no accountability none
how come she's taking it now I want to
hear what she's taking accountability of
I think she started towards the end of
the show but it was kind of like after
we like ran around with circles for her
for two and a half hours and then yeah
so those reasons why and I liked how
Daley tried to change the topic to
anyone else and it's still he was
talking about herself yep about 100 not
100
why is she doing this everything's 100
because she doesn't let them talk no no
I'm not I'm just saying like no because
she was mating she's making it like it
was like see the guy's doing it digging
himself in the hole
she was kind of just saying it before
him but really there was a reason why
yeah no way I 100 accept the person I
was at 23 to who I am at 29 we're not
the same if I know what I know now we me
and him will be happy okay and this was
my point on the show because then she
was like I was I was feminine now and I
was like okay what did you do to get
there and then she knows then but she
knows now her and her husband would be
happy to give her but you know it now so
why aren't you together she's been
working on herself what she said just
now is if she knew now what she knew
then but if you know now enough to make
your marriage work and you're working
towards making your marriage work why
won't you use that knowledge that you've
got now to make it work well I'm like
let me talk to your husband what would
he say have you changed and and that's
that's the real indicator would your
husband say she's changed
no it's not that he was right I think
both of us were growing at different we
communication definitely was the problem
she accepts the decision
years to accept it but I accept it I can
see what I needed to do for myself do
you get what I mean but you know what
yeah do you see the difference between
this conversation that's been had as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible